stanley kubrick's a clockwork orange is
going to be released on 4k ultra hd
blu-ray and digital on september 21st a
brilliant movie
and the actor who was the star of that
film
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
malcolm mcdowell right here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
very well rich how's it going better for
talking to you a huge fan of yours and
this
film
and uh have you seen it in the 4k ultra
had you have you been able to see it and
is there anything different
about it have you seen it i haven't no i
don't there's nothing different with the
cut right it's the same movie
um
i can't believe that uh even if it's in
4k
then it's any better than it was when it
first came out because kubrick
was such a stickler for the you know
technicalities of the film
it would have been perfect but um
you know i love 4k it's great isn't it
especially when you're watching football
from england
yes
you feel like you're there you know so
i'd be very interested to see what it's
like i'm sure it's absolutely amazing
you know what was it like um for you to
be directed by stanley kubrick
back in your day malcolm oh god that's
such a
an open-ended question you know um
stanley you know didn't do much
directing on the set it's it's really
interesting um
i'd be hard
put you know to think of a time well the
only time he actually gave me any
direction was um
coming through a door
i came through the door and he goes um
can you be
you know can something be happening i
went like what coming through the door
because yeah why don't you think of um
dave prowse
dave prowsers mr universe
uh uh think of him making love to milena
cannonero who was like a little tiny
stick
and of course when i opened the door i
had a sneezing grin on my face
that was the best piece of direction he
gave me is actually the only piece of
direction that i remember because you
know stanley was um you know he did all
the work with you or with me
before we started the film there was
like six to eight months of
preparation and uh finding
locations and
costuming and all the whole
rigmarole that goes on
and i was out of this house you know
two or three times a week going through
stuff with them and having lunches and
dinners and all the rest of it and
that's where he really i think
kind of
gauged you know what i was like whether
he could trust me and
all the rest of it and um
the actual person that helped me the
most
in the role
was actually not stanley kubrick
but another director who was a great
friend and a man i loved dearly called
lindsay anderson
who i done my first movie if with and if
is
the movie that stanley saw and cast me
so i did no auditions or anything my
audition was if
this movie which is a brilliant movie
and i asked lindsay if he would mind
reading the script because he groaned
and having to read somebody else's
script you know
anyway he did read it and
i went around to see him
and the first thing he said when i came
in through his flat was
thank god i don't have to make this film
right
which kind of made my heart sink and i
said
well it's not your kind of material you
couldn't make this film this is you know
this is going to be um you know
commercial film
because i knew that would irritate him a
bit because of course he'd love to make
a commercial movie you know
and he'd made enough of the art stuff
and um
anyway i said look can you give me any
help at all on this because he goes yes
there is a close-up of you in if
when you open the gymnasium doors to
look at the prefix to be beaten
you look at them and you smile
that's how you play this part
because you need to you need to have
some sort of psychosis that you're
enjoying
the violence right like that's no no
that's not it what is it then no no
it's just a question of style
it's just a que it's not him smiling at
the fact that he's
beating and raping and stuff which is
part of it of course but it's
really a matter of attitude
you can have that smile on your face
like it's a real like screw you kind of
smile
uh
but not necessarily when he's
you know when those violence involved
it's in fact the first scene was me
taking off my pajamas and rolling over
showing the doctor my bear and she
sticks
a hypodermic needle in me and uh gives
me a shot that was my first film the the
first shooting i did on the movie
and um
and you know um
of course stanley because it was my
first shot said
you know i'm not going to use a
retractable needle i i want you to
i went what
you want me to take a shot
i said what's the shot going to be he
goes well it's distilled water
i said well this imagino that was the
actress
he goes yeah she's practicing now
anyway stanley
i mean she's got all this dialogue and
you're expecting her to give me a shot
as a doctor
i mean that's asking a lot
knowing i did not want to do it yes but
it was my first shot so what am i going
to say i'm not going to say no
and of course
i look at her and i see
she's uh
sweating on the top of her top lip
that's not a good sign
that's not a good sign i'd agree i can
see her with the needle and i can see
she's already shaking
and so
she goes uh now i'm give and she has
quite a lot of dialogue you know
um and she's asking me how i feel
and i go well i what about these videos
i mean
i started to feel sick i mean what and
she goes
this shot will help you now turn over
and i kind of do a little thing with the
with the band of the pajama you know and
and then turn over and
she literally
threw that hypodermic needle into me
like it was going into a rhino
it went up to the hilt
because i think she'd been told don't
baby it you got to get it in fast
and clean
well she got it in and
it went up to the hilt and i gave her
but i remembered lindsay's advice you
smile
i had this eating grin on my face
and then she just wanted to get the damn
thing over with and started to pump this
thing so fast
that this water had nowhere to go
and i left
i mean 10 feet in the air michael jordan
would have been proud of me yes sir i
mean vertical takeoff it hurt so much it
was like a huge cramping it took like an
hour
to disperse this bubble in my
i don't mean to laugh but i mean my you
know this is this is the sort of
thoughts that that you would have
sitting here as a as a a fan of the film
that kubrick wanted to make sure that
everything was as real as possible i've
got malcolm mcdowell here on the rich
eisen show what about the scene
where
you are
um
having your eyes kept open
by
a clamp a surgical device that was used
for eye surgery that was the real deal
did you did you get
uh what was that like for you as the
actor uh malcolm mcdowell
how would it be for you it would be
dreadful it would be positive exactly
what it was
there's no way around it it was horrible
but
you know
he had a doctor there to persuade me
that it was
gonna be fine
the doctor was a nice guy and uh
said oh yes well you won't feel anything
because you're going to be anesthetized
and i went ah okay so and how long will
that last oh yeah but every you know
10 15 seconds
i have to put artificial tears in your
eyes because otherwise
they'll dry up it's not blinking
i mean oh dark you won't forget that he
goes no no
but then of course stanley gave the guy
a line of dialogue
all he had to say was
how are you feeling little alex
and he kept saying what's your name and
i'm like jesus doc don't even say the
line who cares
it'll be cut anyway
and uh of course i'm tapping my foot you
know
the 15 seconds
i'm going get it in dark god that's
drying up here drying up
and um
and it's true i did not feel it at the
time
but these lid locks they're called
um
were falling out of my eyes because
of course they used in delicate eye
operations but you're usually lying on
your back
you're not sitting up watching videos
and
you know they kept slipping out and
every time they fell out they dragged
across my cornea
and i got really messed up corneas
and it wasn't until i was driving into
my street in london
that the um
the pain i cannot even describe it
it was so horrendous it drove me to the
to the point of madness
i mean literally
slamming my head into you know the wall
it was so painful
luckily my doctor lived around the
corner
and um
obviously the he knew it was serious and
he came running around with this bag and
he had some morphine in it and gave me a
shot and um
i was out
for the night and the next morning i
woke up you know the eyes very
heals very quickly and it wasn't healed
totally but the pain had got completely
gone and the cuts had healed
felt they just felt like i had sand in
the eyes you know did kubrick know this
that you needed this healthy yeah he
knew it okay he knew it i mean i told
him
and he was like
well this is his sense of humor so when
i got out of the thing
the doctor put a pad on one of my eyes
because he obviously saw something
he didn't have his microscope or
anything with him right
and uh so stanley came up he looked and
he goes oh gee well can we shoot on this
eye
now that you know it was stanley's sense
of humor
and um i mean yes daddy we can shoot on
this eye you can destroy both and my
site
and then i'll sue you
wow malcolm mcdowell here on the rich
eisen show i could literally talk to you
for hours about this but
is it true you ad-libbed
singing singing in the rain while you
conducted the mayhem in the film
uh that that was your why'd you do that
where'd you come up with that one you
know um
well in the scene
um alex is at his most euphoric
and uh euphoria
is
you know com
is put in a beautiful box by gene kelly
and that movie singing in the rain
and if you want to replicate euphoria
that's it that's what hollywood has
given us and it was so
iconic and extraordinary and stayed with
me i thought it was a young man maybe a
child
and
it was so extraordinary that um
so when i started when he asked me if i
could dance
and i of course i can't really dance
because i said can i dance i was so
bored like sitting around for five days
and doing nothing and i launched into it
and on the beats would be smacking and
you know doing all that
as a kind of joke
and i looked at stanley he was laughing
so hard he had his handkerchief stuffed
in his mouth
and he put me in his car we drove back
to his house
because we were on location and uh he
bought the rights to singing in the rain
we came back and we
shot the whole thing
using that as the the basis of the scene
so it was a choice by you and you felt
the freedom to do it because kubrick
because we had vincent d'onofrio who was
one of the stars of fullmetal jacket on
a couple years ago saying that he hardly
ever got a direction from from kubrick
he would always say to him like what are
you thinking that would be essentially
it and so
you felt the freedom to come up like i'm
going to do it this way and he loved and
he laughed and now that's that's what he
demands
that's what he wants that you're a
collaborator
you're not just an actor you're
collaborating with him on it
and that i said to him ah now i know why
you love peter so much peter sellers
because he'd do all these funny voices
and you get to choose
and he laughed he said you're so right
he goes yeah peter was great at that
and you know peter sellers doing that
whole thing
as dr strangelove in the wheelchair and
the nazi salute that that was all a kind
of gag you know joke and it was so
extraordinary but that's how great
things in movies happen sometimes
they're not scripted they're between
you know they're it's a feeling that has
to come out at some point in a weird way
stanley
it didn't have to give me any direction
you know he just
he just really supplied
the
you know atmosphere to do it and um
and that's all you need really so i
guess my last question for you malcolm
mcdowell is how did you come out of this
um you know you're you're telling me
about scratch corneas and you know uh
injections and things of that nature and
i imagine just uh performing this and
going through all this had to you know
uh you you had to
to get into the role had to leave your
your own senses on occasion i mean how
did shooting and filming a clockwork
orange well hey
i'm not a method actor so i mean i took
the cod piece off at the end of the day
and went for dinner
you know
there was no question okay
you know it being a psychologically
damaging
i mean that's a that's [ __ ] i'm an
actor you know
that's what i do
um
and um
you know that don't forget the shoot was
i think sort of eight or nine months
and there's two or three instances of
injury that's it
so most of the time
of course there was
it was just really
you know trying to find in every scene
trying to find the magic
and we used to he and i used to laugh
about it
and i mean there was one scene he came
to me and he goes well
you know that's it that's it he goes uh
i can't i i can't shoot that that's
boring
and i went stanley that's the way we're
gonna do it no come on i mean we gotta
do something i mean no no no the
audience
need a
moment to recoup
you know this
and it was actually the um
alex's um
entrance into prison
and we had a guy there was telling us
you know as we had not been to prison he
was giving us all the insights and what
happened stand behind the white line and
empty your pockets and all this kind of
stuff and
i went you know i no alex is going
now he's been caught he's going to play
the game
you know and and um
and you know
it turned out listen very well well i
would remember that scene it wasn't
boring i mean you were told to pick
think something up and put it back down
properly you were being very
you know uh what you know cocky about
that this was that's the i'm i don't
remember that being boring right that
was a terrorist i don't think it was
boring either so we had a bit of a there
we go well why don't you get to look at
it look at it tomorrow yeah davies and
then
we'll see
and i never heard another word about it
so
i knew it was fine well i like i said i
could talk to you for hours about this
sort of stuff and then obviously the
rest of your career but i guess you know
this is a radio tv show with commercials
so i guess the phrase we're we're
victims of being very nice talking to
you and i know that you
generally do sports i do but i um i'd
love to tell you about a file and god
bless you for it big time i would i said
that we're victims of the modern age
right now that we have to throw at a
commercial break buttons are the modern
age absolutely we're poor poor boys i
love the film it's just truly one of my
favorites and let's get you back on
we'll talk about the rest of your career
whatever else you want to promote and
maybe a little bit of liverpool right
that's your club
oh
now we're talking okay
right okay yeah sounds great okay
malcolm thanks for the time
same to you that's malcolm mcdowell
right here in the rich eisen show
wow
i mean there's so many other scenes from
that film that we've been going to
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here